dan is with us dan is in Nashville hi
Dan how are you alright nice talking to
you Dave I just heard you one day when I
switch in the radio and I said I need to
talk to you and looked you up on the
computer and I don't Harlem is uh has
nothing to do with me it has all to do
with my sister who lives in New York
she's up on age about 70 and you know
when you get these credit card
applications in she would fill them out
made send Cod like crazy she pays the
bare minimum and now she's owing $50,000
and net like you've been talking about
you know they're driving a crazy and
everything like this and I was just
wondering if you know of anybody
somebody who could sort this stuff out
for her you know how to work it out
maybe so she could pay one bill or you
know put combine them and put them all
together and she would pay it off that
way I don't think that er is what
matters is just she doesn't have any
money
yeah she has no money she leave one bill
or ten bills to you know ten one hundred
dollar bills or one one thousand dollar
bill doesn't matter yeah you know in
terms of monthly payments the number of
payments in what's driving her crazy the
fact she has no money to pay her bills
is what's driving her crazy
what's her income um she uh on Social
Security I really don't know too much
about it because she's like very
secretive what does she have any money
saved that you're aware of no
the Shyama home she has a condo that is
paid off for it's in Flushing
but um does she live in it uh sorry
does she live in yes she lives in it
what is it worth
it's uh she's like a hoarder yeah what
is what is it worth um right now I say
not too much because not too many things
work in there the a condition does work
the heater doesn't work the stove
doesn't work you know and stuff like
that and it's just full of just full of
stuff she buys 10 of shirts that shows
like she's got some psychological issues
yeah yeah we know that but well here's
the problem okay
money problems are very seldom the real
problem they're usually the symptom of
something else that's going on and so
what you're describing to me is to
someone that has some mental health
issues and they're she's probably going
to no matter what happens she's probably
going to struggle with money unless she
deals with those mental health issues
she's willing to live in a condo that's
not functioning and um and is still
continuing to buy things as she can't
afford that you know obviously you and I
understand her actions are completely
illogical I don't they're the same human
being would not make these actions it's
not mere irresponsibility at this stage
it's down into mental illness have you
got family in the area that can
encourage her to get some counseling no
we'll all spread out across the country
I just thought least let me see show you
what I'm talking about let's pretend
that you and I wrote her a check for a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars we
paid off all of her debt and we fixed
her condo up in five years she's gonna
be right back here again isn't she my
wife said the same thing and that's why
that's not being mean because we've
treated the symptom rather than treated
the problem
that's what I meant by the problem is
her mental illness and it's sad for you
to watch as her brother you love her and
it's sad for me to hear the story so I
would encourage you and maybe another
sibling to sit down with her make a trip
to New York and see if we can get her
engaged in some counseling and if you
and your wife paid for anything I would
pay for that and if you guys need to
hook up we've got Dave Ramsey certified
coaches that have been through our our
Coach training all over America and I'm
sure we have one in that area that would
help you with the money stuff but
they're trained to not take your money
for coaching financial coaching in that
situation unless they've dealt with the
other issues because we would be ripping
you off you see what I'm saying yeah
well we want to be able to actually do
some good for her and what's happening
is that you know she's gonna until she
fixes this broken spot in her spirit
then I mean probably with God's help you
know it she needs some wholeness there
to be able to walk forward in it because
there's several things here going on
here they're really really sad one is
the debt the stress from that one is
that she's living in squalor um two is
that she three is that she seems to be
very much completely out of control in
terms of her purchases and her spending
and the way she lives her life and it's
just it's getting worse instead of
better
and so the loving thing to do would be
confront her and try to get her into
some mental health counseling and if you
wanted to pay for anything if I were her
brother that's what I would be willing
to pay for in that situation but giving
her money is just going to be flushing
it down the toilet because she's going
to keep doing the same things from the
same broken spots in her spirit so sorry
you're facing us Dan it's hard times man
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my
my own youtube channel yes that's right
kind of better in the dayroom to channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you